welcome to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i'm in
charge around here one and only
full-time host
i am joined today by a special temporary
guest co-host his name is craig knuckles
greg how you doing
i'm doing well thank you for the
opportunity absolutely uh not anytime
you know i'm not gonna make it an open
invitation but i do appreciate you
having here today
um
i tell you what before we get into
things i want to start out with a couple
i basically want to start by showing
some products
let's make this thing profitable here so
uh if you want to support the show you
can always
subscribe and download our new diet app
called macro factor
you could theoretically subscribe to the
mass research review pretty good stuff
goes out the first of every month
or when you stock up on supplements you
could you could go to bulk
supplements.com
use the discount code sbs pod and get
five percent off your order
uh so with that out of the way how goes
the road to the stage
uh the road to the stage goes well um
after
or in in the last episode i called my
shot uh i said that
within the upcoming week i was gonna get
below 240.
that occurred so uh
call me the bambino of gradual weight
loss i suppose
uh so yeah at this point i'm i'm waking
up under 240 about half the time uh give
or take
my my trend weight is still ticking down
uh a little over a pound a week um
and i've got some pretty big uh
milestones some some additional pretty
big milestones coming up which
ultimately
don't matter that much uh
because all of life is meaningless in
the first place but to me i agree to me
they feel important
uh so getting below 240 that's obviously
very cool uh when i get below 239 that
will be another big milestone because
that'll mean i'm halfway towards
ultimately what i'm trying to get to on
this cut so i started at 278 and i'm
trying to get to sub 200
and we'll see how that goes i mean if
i'm just
diced to the socks at 210 whatever i'm
not gonna shoot for for sub 200 uh just
for the sake of it i don't think that's
going to happen though so i i want to
see one something on the scale again
just for fun
uh so yeah 239 will be halfway there and
then 238 obviously since i started at
278
that'll mean that i'm down 40 pounds so
i've got a nice little run of numbers
where uh they they de-mark interesting
milestones um
so yeah that's all coming up
everything's going well
and uh i i'm
excited to hit those milestones um in
terms of
i guess like insights beyond just like
uh you know
just recounting numbers which i don't
think
is particularly interesting content um
one thing that
i guess like one uh
struggle i've been having that that's
stating it too strongly um but yeah one
thing that's been a little bit
challenging of late um which i'm
pretty proud of myself for being able to
cope with and continue onward is uh
ever since macro factor launched
uh i've been
incredibly busy uh because
i'm generally a pretty busy guy and this
is uh basically
another
uh what amounts to a full-time job on
top of everything i was already doing
uh so i've had way less time to cook
than normal so that means fewer you know
good nutritious
home-cooked meals um
and so like for for lunch i've still
been meal prepping and
having good uh
non-calorie dense wholesome food
for dinner on the other hand though it's
just way more convenience food like just
eat what i got to eat to hit my calorie
and protein targets
but certainly putting way less time and
effort into it because i have way less
time to devote to cooking uh and
just way less time for things like sleep
uh and and other facets of life so
anyway um
yeah uh
what they say is true um convenience
type foods you know uh
ordering from fast food restaurants like
last night we had um
just like
uh freezer chicken patty sandwiches like
whatever uh those are actually [ __ ]
good though um not not the best like
quote unquote diet food but man i i love
a good frozen chicken patty uh cooked of
course not still frozen yeah you don't
want to eat it frozen that'd be yeah
that'd be bad but uh but yeah i mean
it it definitely makes a big difference
with regards to hunger uh both because
like the meals are just smaller in terms
of total volume and mass so
you know there's there's less to uh to
sit in your stomach and and trigger some
of those like gastric peptide hormones
um
and yeah it just doesn't keep you full
for nearly as long
um so that that has
made things a little bit more
challenging um but now i've i've done a
pretty good job of
uh
like we talked about last time or did we
talk about this on the last podcast or
did we talk about this in mass audio i
think we talked about it in mass audio i
don't have any memories anymore yeah
that's totally fine but uh just the
concept of like
accepting hunger
um so yeah i've i've been doing a pretty
good job of that but uh
yeah i mean one of the common pieces of
advice that like we've given and just
everyone in the fitness industry gives
is like oh yeah if you're having trouble
sticking to a diet and dealing with a
lot of hunger
eating at home and like home-cooked
meals
it's a good thing
and
that's
i think that is generally good advice
and
uh my my experiences in recent weeks
certainly bear that out i think
sometimes the advice is given in a
somewhat tone-deaf way because like at
this point if someone just said like hey
man if you're hungry just cook more say
[ __ ] you man like i literally don't have
time to cook more um and i think that
that's
a situation a lot of people find
themselves in um
i mean a lot of people out there just
have very busy lives and you know
certain priorities take precedence
uh but yeah so
i
i do think that that
advice could often be given in a more uh
empathetic manner than it often is uh
but man that's
it's good advice i'm i'm really looking
forward to uh
the things hopefully calming down a
little bit soon so
i can go back to cooking more because it
really
uh has been making a pretty substantial
difference with regards to hunger yeah
um
we'll see if that nickname catches on
what was that the the great bambino of
uh gradual gradual weight loss we'll see
if that uh if that really sticks sure um
all right how's how's your road to
enlightenment going well before i get
there you would have been blown away by
the stir fry i made last night oh my god
what was it
uh it was a tofu like asian stir fry
which is literally the only meal i make
very nice uh
are you familiar with
the concept of cornstarch
i am
so
apparently it works uh made my
it does as advertised made my my tofu
very crispy in the oven which is
oh that's how you're using it yeah very
important
and uh
vegetables when you're sauteing them
frozen vegetables
turns out temperature and timing both
important
that is true so yeah it was awesome the
vegetables were great the crisp the
direction i thought you were going with
the corn starch was like homemade sauces
absolutely not well because uh
not all but a lot of thickened asian
sauces are thickened with corn starch
yeah um
so yeah if you ever want to uh make even
more custom stir fries
uh
cornstarch is is pretty clutch in the
sauce game nice well yeah so i i'm
crushing it in the kitchen i'm also
crushing it
on the path to enlightenment the road to
enlightenment i have
two updates um
the road to enlightenment's very
competitive and i'm winning by a pretty
comfortable margin
so uh
one serious thing that i think is kind
of helpful um
so
here's the thing you start getting into
this like secular buddhism and
mindfulness
and what i noticed is like it's the
concepts are easy to grasp
intellectually but hard to implement in
your real life you know
and for a while there i was just kind of
grasping them but not implementing them
and then i reached kind of stage two
which is
implementing them when you least need
them which is basically like when things
are going good and you're not stressed
or in a bad mood you're like oh i can be
very content in everything school
and then there's like one little
stressor and you revert back to your
typical kind of thinking patterns which
is
not great
i'm really stoked because
i have this track record of failure
where i'll be doing well and then
there's like one stressor and all that
stuff goes out the window and i revert
back to normal yeah but i finally am
starting to have some of those instances
where
you know
we we do a lot of stuff online sometimes
people will just kind of come at you
with terrible vibes
and i'm starting to notice that in real
time i'm able to see that
and mindfully respond and really have a
much different approach to it like the
knee-jerk reaction a lot of times
especially if somebody's being
like a real jackass is like to get
defensive right or to like match their
bad vibes um and i've had quite a few
instances uh recently where i've noticed
there's kind of a metaphor i've i've
heard in in various buddhist teachings
which is like
you know it goes back to a story i'll
ruin the detail so i won't try to get it
right but the general idea is like if
somebody gives you a gift
if i try to give you a gift and you
reject it say sorry i can't accept that
yeah the gift still belongs to me i
tried to give it to you but you didn't
accept it right
and that's kind of the metaphor like
when somebody is trying to just
introduce terrible vibes into your day
you don't have to accept it
and it thinking back to that metaphor
i've been like oh you're trying to give
me a terrible afternoon not going to
happen or you're trying to drag me into
a ridiculous argument here that's not
going to work so i've seen that more and
more and i've been stoked about it but
nice
the really big update
is that i did in fact reach
enlightenment
i achieved it i reached nirvana that
might be record time i it could be
something anyone has ever achieved uh
complete enlightenment as quickly as you
have there have been people who did it
in one lifetime but i'm not aware of
anyone who did it in under two years
or under one year nice um no so i
i go to a lake that's like you know 10
minutes from my house and i meditate
sometimes
uh much like yourself
believe it or not i'm also quite busy at
the moment given that we are busy
because of the same thing checks out um
so i was meditating by the lake and i
transcended into a completely different
realm of existence and
what i mean by that is i laid down on
the ground in the park and passed out
and
some people
some people would be walking by and say
that's a disheveled clearly uh
you know this man is not taking care of
himself he's in his 30s he's passed out
on the ground in public i don't know
that people would assume you're in your
30s by looking at you well nonetheless
it's been a rough 30-some years it has
so
the typical passerby would look at me
passed out on the ground and say that
man is at rock bottom yeah no no
quite the opposite
that's enlightenment
you've ascended to the mountaintop yeah
so i reject that not rock bottom it's
there's nothing pathetic about falling
asleep on the ground in the park
uh and i was pretty stoked because
nothing bad happened to me
when i was
asleep on the ground in the park with
all my valuable belongings around me so
that's good yeah
uh yeah that's the the road to
enlightenment so what about feed to
strength
feeds of strength yeah so there are
there are a lot and i know that these
segments have a tendency to drag when
there are lots when there are a lot of
feats of strength so
uh i'm gonna start by just kind of
listing things not talking about them in
much detail uh treat it as honorable
mentions
um
unfortunately for some of these actually
it's not even that unfortunate i doubt
people actually listen to this podcast
and say like ooh did greg and eric talk
about my feat of strength um
but anyway yeah unfortunately for for
some of these folks uh there were
several big meets pretty recently a lot
of strong people doing a lot of strong
things
got to keep it moving so just going to
start by by basically listing a few
and then talk about two in more depth
uh so to start with
jonathan caico hit a world record bench
press in the 93 kilogram class drug
tested amanda lawrence had a world
record deadlift in the tested 84 kilo
class uh christy hawkins hit uh or i
think broke her own world record in the
75 kilo uh untested no wraps division uh
joe sullivan uh
set a world record squad in the hundred
kilogram untested no wraps division uh
beating a world record that um
jordan wong just recently set
so belated congratulations to jordan and
congratulations to both jordan and joe
uh and
bryce ah man i meant to uh google how to
pronounce his name uh i think it's
crawl check
i'm sure that's wrong i feel bad uh
anyway
world record deadlift in the tested 120
kilo class uh and finally jessica
bittner a world record squat in the 84
kilo tested division um
so like i said a lot of strong people
doing a lot of strong stuff but then the
two i want to talk about uh
slightly more
is tamara walcott
recently hit the heaviest female
deadlift of all time
she pulled 288 and a half kilos or
636 pounds
um
you know that's
an objectively great deadlift for anyone
uh obviously incredibly great deadlift
for a woman seen as that is the most
weight a woman has ever pulled uh so
congrats to her also the the video will
be linked in the show notes i'd
recommend checking it out
it's a very solid deadlift moves very
smoothly
very clean lockout
and
a lot of
world record deadlifts are
it seems like they're basically right at
the edge of someone's grip strength
where
you you just look at it and you say like
ah well if they threw on straps maybe
they could get another 40 50 pounds um i
i do think at the top top levels um grip
strength limits a lot of deadlifters but
man when she pulls it she just stands
there and lock out for
uh what seemed like about five seconds
just just chilling drinking the moment
in um so very very solid lift very
impressive uh and would strongly
recommend checking that out uh and then
finally people who follow powerlifting a
bit probably uh
knew that that this is where the feats
of strength uh was headed in this
episode
john hack hit a just batshit total
recently uh he totaled
1000.5 kilograms or
225.7
pounds or
2205.7 pounds uh in the 90 kilogram or
198 pound division with no knee wraps
uh
that's ridiculous um
so
there's now a 75 kilogram
gap between himself and the number two
in his own weight class
uh he also broke the world record total
in the 100 kilogram or 220 pound
division uh while again competing at 198
broke yuri belkin's total by 28 kilos
we've talked about yuri on the podcast
multiple times uh
also
an incredibly strong lifter but uh hack
is out totaling him by 28 kilos in one
weight class down
and also that broke uh jamal browner's
110 kilogram or 242 total by half a by
half a kilo
so um
yeah in in one fell swoop uh john hack
who
is already clearly the goat at 198 uh
set the no wraps untested world record
total all the way up to the 242 class um
which i mean
there's that that doesn't require
commentary that's
that's a just
nutty total so uh
congrats to him uh
jealous of how strong he is
uh but
that's cool seems like a good guy
awesome good stuff
so uh the next segment here is going to
be a research review segment
um kind of just reviewing a couple broad
topics more so providing a bit of an
update
um
i'll be honest i truly cannot remember
the last time i talked about these
topics on the podcast
these are topics that come up frequently
whenever i'm like doing a guest spot on
a different podcast i talk about them in
the mass audio all the time
but the reason i want to revisit this
topic which is refeeds and diet breaks
is because obviously within the last few
weeks we launched a diet app
and so
users have had questions about you know
what's a refeed or a diet break
why might i do one how can i do one
within the app you know so
it kind of reminded me that it's a good
time to revisit this topic another
reason i want to revisit this topic is
the last time i really put thoughts down
in writing on it
was probably 2019 it was probably the
the metabolic adaptation manual uh on
the website stronger by science.com
and uh
at that time it was really clear that
there were going to be some new findings
coming down the pipeline
[Music]
and so a lot of that riding was like ah
this seems promising but
in two years we're going to know a lot
more well
two years have passed and we do know a
lot more so i want to dive into it first
a quick recap
kind of setting the stage with a problem
statement so
when an individual is losing weight
right so somebody
has lost for example
10 of their body mass or more
if we bring someone in in that state we
might notice that their total daily
energy expenditure has dropped uh by up
to 25
relative to where they started
you know in energy balance at their
previous weight
so
25 drop in total daily energy
expenditure is substantial
now
not all of that is adaptive in nature
some of that is because
an individual has
uh you know a lower thermic effect of
feeding because they're eating less some
of that a much larger portion is related
to the fact that they are now
a smaller person with less metabolically
active tissue
so those are not adaptive changes that's
just what happens when you restrict
energy intake and become a smaller human
being who weighs less
but there is an adaptive component and
this is where metabolic adaptation comes
into play uh about half of that 25 drop
up to half
uh can be adaptive in nature
and
up to 80 or 90 of that adaptation that
adaptive component is driven by
reductions in non-exercise activity
thermogenesis
and that is the energy that's expended
when you are
technically
you know
active but you're not doing structured
exercise so doing things around the
house fidgeting in your chair things of
that nature
now the drop in non-exercise activity
thermogenesis or neat
is
dictated by the hypothalamus and the key
signal driving that
is a drop in leptin so leptin is
responsive to
reductions in body fat if we lose a lot
of fat mass those fat cells are putting
less leptin into circulation
the hypothalamus gets the hint
and this kind of cascade of events the
sequence kind of unfolds leptin is also
sensitive to short-term fluctuations in
food intake
so
going into a big caloric deficit
even before significant fat loss occurs
that will elicit a drop in leptin
and
leptin seems to be
particularly responsive to carbohydrate
intake so
uh
you know even if you are introducing the
same caloric deficit if you're doing it
from pretty substantial carb restriction
that might have a bigger impact on the
drop in leptin acutely than if you were
doing fat restriction instead and
usually it's a mixture of both but you
know just a representative example
so
we are losing fat mass we are in an
energy deficit leptin is dropping
that feeds into the hypothalamus
structure of the brain that is
really responsible for controlling
overall energy balance so the
hypothalamus gets the signal and says oh
that's not great
because the main priority uh in this
context for the hypothalamus is to make
sure that we've got enough energy to
survive
and do what we need to do so there's all
these downstream effects it affects
thyroid hormones sex hormones um a lot
of other stuff hunger hormones hunger
and satiety regulation but one of the
big things that people talk about
is of course the drop in total daily
energy expenditure and that that makes
all the sense in the world because total
daily energy expenditure drops you want
to keep losing weight theoretically in
this example
and so you're going to have to keep
going a little bit lower a little bit
lower
with your calorie target to maintain
uh an appropriately sized energy deficit
so
one of the things to bring up here
before we talk about refeed and diet
break research is
who's actually adapting the most here
you know
who is really being impacted by
particularly substantial drops in total
daily energy expenditure
generally speaking it tends to be people
who have lost very substantial amounts
of body fat people who are currently
at really low body fat levels so like
you know high level physique athletes
who are ready for a show
and people who are in a particularly
large caloric deficit with particularly
aggressive carbohydrate restriction
so
this is where
refeeds and diet breaks come into play
there's really nothing we can do about
the fat loss part if fat loss is the
goal
then
loss of fat mass is
by definition unavoidable it's a feature
not a bug it's a feature not a bug so
that part of the whole leptin balance
leptin regulation
isn't really modifiable uh unless we're
going with exogenous leptin
administration which has been done
in the research and is tremendously
effective
at offsetting
essentially everything that you would
associate with metabolic adaptation
but
theoretically we can intervene and act
upon dietary variables in the the
short-term sense and so the whole theory
with
refeeds and diet breaks is
you know is it possible that by
manipulating the energy deficit and by
manipulating carbohydrate intake that we
could get a transient short-term acute
reprieve from some of these uh things
related to low leptin the idea is can we
modify the diet to just temporarily
increase leptin a little bit maybe that
helps out with you know thyroid hormones
sex hormones hunger and appetite
regulation maybe it even ramps up total
daily energy expenditure a little bit so
that we don't have to keep going lower
and lower and lower and lower
that is the general premise and so
there are basically
like i said two different strategies
here refeeds usually what you're gonna
do
is
one two maybe three days uh throughout
the week where you bump up
energy intake almost exclusively
from carbohydrate so it's basically like
usually two or three
really high carb days and the idea is
you know i would say it's probably
preferable to put those in a row if
you're gonna do it but the idea is if we
kind of ramp things up for two or three
days in a row maybe we can get leptin up
and keep it up so that the hypothalamus
gets the message and says okay let's
let's scale back some of these adaptive
processes we seem to be in an okay spot
here
so usually with a refeed it's only you
know
two maybe three days a week
and it's going to be a relatively
aggressive thing because it's not the
entire week so you're going to go
at least to maintenance but usually even
a little bit above maintenance with a
refeed in terms of your calorie intake
diet breaks are a little different same
premise
that that sounds a lot like uh
oh what was it called man back in the
back in the mid-aughts
there was a book
by
dr morrow d pascal or pascali uh i think
it was called either the metabolic diet
or the anabolic diet
uh
but yeah it was
something approaching a protein-sparing
modified fast throughout the week with
either one or two days of high carb
brief eating on the weekends
um
i don't know if i remember those details
correctly but
that was that was very popular back in
the day um
this uh this general approach yeah so
that's refeeds right
diet breaks are a little different but a
similar premise uh from a theoretical
perspective the idea with a diet break
is that it's going to be less aggressive
you're rarely going to see a diet break
that goes above maintenance in terms of
the calorie intake
but it's longer in duration so a diet
break will usually be at least a week
sometimes two in the literature and
theoretically you could go longer if you
wanted to you could say you know
you might have a pretty ambitious weight
loss goal and say i'm going to lose 20
pounds now
chill there for a month or two and then
lose the other 20. you know you could do
something like that uh so we've got
these two different strategies that can
they kind of fall within the umbrella of
non-linear dieting strategies because
it's not just getting from point a to
point b throughout the diet it's you
know
going along taking a break or ramping up
calories and then you know taking
another dip and so on and so forth
so there is some
reason to believe that these might be
beneficial
within certain contexts and like i said
it all comes back to
those who
seem to be
impacted by metabolic adaptation the
most
probably have the most to gain from
usually using these types of non-linear
strategies so there is a paper by uh
coelho
doval
there's no way i pronounce that
correctly but i'm gonna keep pushing
because that's what i do i keep pushing
forward
what they were looking at the title of
the paper is the benefits of behaving
badly on occasion successful regulation
by planned hedonic deviations
these were one day
refeeds and this was not like a
physiology group it wasn't like a
you know a nutrition group or an
exercise science group this was more
like a behavior psychology kind of
research group and what they found was
by having these plan deviations these
one day refeeds that you know this would
carry over more to a refeed than a diet
break most likely um they did find
higher self-regulatory ability uh or
better self-regulatory ability
higher positive affect um you know
better the individuals that had
these one-day refeeds develop more
strategies to overcome temptations with
regards to food better motivation to
pursue goals and similar weight loss
within the observation period so this
was more looking at some of the
psychological impacts and a one-day
refeed that was pre-planned so that the
individual doesn't internalize it as
going off of their plan actually did
have some positive benefits when it
comes to
psychology and motivation i mean i can
tell you that's
exactly what i've been doing for my
current cut yeah um
yeah i'm not like doing a two or three
day controlled carb heavy
refeed strategy for
leptin or anything like that uh we have
family dinner once a week um
and yeah i mean i i just pre-planned
like yeah i'm gonna eat like 4 000
calories that day uh
don't really track anything
always eat at least 3 000 probably
generally below 5 000 most of the time
but
i i go into the week anticipating
hey like i can
i can practice some restraint for six
days out of the week because on saturday
i'm gonna have a grand old time um
and you know i i am uh
i think like pretty hedonically
motivated by food
so knowing that that is something i can
always look forward to at the end of the
week um and don't just have to
completely forgo for weeks or months at
a time uh that's i i think
yeah i i don't know that that's doing
anything particularly interesting
physiologically but like you're saying i
think i think psychologically that's
that's been pretty helpful for me yeah
now
there is um when we look back at some of
the older research there's also reason
for optimism or cause for optimism when
it comes to the actual tangible outcomes
so there was a meta-analysis by harris
and colleagues where they were looking
at uh
essentially looking at different types
of diet breaks uh and seeing how that
would affect weight loss
and
what they found was generally speaking
the the pooled effect estimate leaned in
favor of better weight loss in groups
that had some type of a diet break type
strategy so a kind of a more sustained
break from being in a caloric deficit
and what i thought was interesting there
weren't a ton of studies that made it
into the meta-analysis but
just looking at the effect sizes the
largest effect sizes
generally were observed in the studies
with the largest magnitude of weight
reduction
and that kind of feeds into that concept
that
[Music]
these types of strategies if we're
expecting them to be physiologically
efficacious
we
we need a problem before we present this
particular solution you know so if
there's a person who's on a very modest
weight loss program and not absolutely
shredded they're probably not dealing
with really major magnitudes of
metabolic adaptation so any strategy
that is hoping to attenuate or mitigate
a metabolic adaptation
by definition is not going to be
tremendously impactful in a scenario
where the magnitude of adaptation is
minimal right
so
they're it's like when people are uh
you know doing a resistance training
program that's very low volume and
they're talking about deload strategies
it's like brother what what are you
deloading you know yeah
and
that that's a good example yeah
so one of the other papers that isn't
brand new but kind of brings us into the
newer class of diet break and refeed
type papers is the matador study which a
lot of people are familiar with it was
available at the time that i wrote the
metabolic adaptation manual so it is
covered in there the matador study was
basically a diet break study two weeks
of dieting two weeks of uh energy
balance weight maintenance uh back and
forth back and forth for a 16 week uh
duration of
energy restriction
so uh
what those study or what what the
results indicated with that study was
basically that
the group who had diet breaks did
achieve better weight loss success over
time uh even when they had kind of a
longer term uh follow-up visit
uh and it did appear
uh that after correcting for energy
expenditure or after correcting for uh
body composition
it attenuated the drop in resting energy
expenditure that occurred over the
duration of weight loss now
one of the reasons that people push back
a little bit you know
take it at face value you would look at
that and say oh cool that's that's tidy
enough right it stopped that reduction
in energy expenditure weight loss
continued uh
very straightforward but the
magnitude
of the attenuation in
[Music]
resting energy expenditure dropping you
know the degree to which that was
attenuated uh mathematically could not
possibly explain the the the magnitude
of difference in weight loss success
yeah i i was uh
i was looking at this figure that you
put in the outline
and i was like i was like oh man 400
calories a day that's a big deal but
then i saw it's in fact kilojoules per
day yeah and uh
not that quite not quite that big of a
deal and it's an unusual pattern yeah
you know it's not like these two nice
linear diverging patterns with one group
versus the other there's a little bit of
volatility and noise there yeah um
and
there's two
sides of that coin you know there's two
potential things to consider there so
the
weight loss clearly was not just
related to
less drop and resting energy expenditure
it's not really debatable
but what happened uh it could be
psychological benefits that promoted
better adherence during the dieting
protocol that's definitely possible
it could be
uh differences in non-exercise activity
thermogenesis that that could be
potentially substantial
i'd have to crunch some numbers to see
if that would be even possible to close
the entire gap
and of course it could be a combination
of those two factors which i think would
probably be the most likely scenario
in my opinion because
in this study there was pretty
substantial weight loss going on you
look at the diet break group uh they
lost like you know over 15 almost 16
kilograms over the course i mean that's
a that's a substantial weight loss
attempt so uh that brings us to some of
the newer papers
when you look at these past studies
they were largely carried out in
untrained populations usually with bmis
over 30.
generally there's kind of a mixture some
of the studies reported null findings
where there just wasn't a big impact
either way
some reported uh modest positive
findings that
indicated that diet breaks or refeeds
were slightly efficacious
but there were no consistently observed
downsides you know there's there are not
a lot of papers where you can look at it
and say man
doing a diet break very regrettable
based on these results or you know the
same thing goes with a refeed but
there's kind of a new wave of research
in this area that focuses on a different
population it's looking more at
you know highly active individuals often
resistance trained who
don't have bmis above 30 who are are you
know in the you know
sub 30 bmi range and so a lot of people
who are using these strategies
kind of fit that mold right they might
have bmi 25 27 28 whatever i lift
weights frequently i'm you know i'm not
trying to lose 16 kilograms i'm trying
to lose a few kilograms and
i think it's valuable to have more data
looking at those individuals uh because
within the fitness space that's that's a
lot of people who are applying these
types of interventions so
there was a paper by campbell and
colleagues
uh i forget what year it came out it's
it's not like brand new by any means we
covered it in mass uh
a volume or two ago
but uh what they had was a two day
refeed strategy
um
and uh they were consecutive days and it
was uh i believe a seven week six or
seven week intervention
and basically what they found this was a
paper that
led to a lot of debate because you know
there were some uh
things where you'd say oh it looks like
this changed pretty positively in this
group but not in that group um you know
if you
look at it uh
you know people who are really
enthusiastic about refeeds we're like oh
man these are incredibly positive
results but there was really only one
outcome i believe that had a significant
interaction a statistically significant
interaction and it indicated that uh
implementing these refeeds had a
positive effect on the retention of dry
fat free mass which is kind of like a
a
estimate of fat free mass that aims to
correct for total body water changes
right so uh when you look at the results
you could say what if we killed you
dissected you
removed all of your adipose tissue and
turned the rest of your flesh into jerky
right yeah
but that's not what they did though
right right i'm just i'm just saying
like conceptually because then i i'd
have to really talk with bill about that
yeah i mean i i think the
the usf
ethics board uh
might have a problem with that correct
uh but you know you look at the results
and you'd say okay it looks like a
slight edge for the refeeds group when
it comes to body composition changes it
looks like a slight edge when it comes
to the drop in resting metabolic rate uh
it was a drop of 38 calories per day in
the uh diet break or the refeed group
i'm sorry and a drop of 78 in the
continuous group so you could look at
that and say okay looks like this is
leaning in favor of the refeed group but
it's not really uh a slam dunk right
it's not a huge magnitude of effect um
and one thing that's really important to
highlight here
these are people who were
you know
body fat percentages the the group
averages were
18 to 22
in a mixed sample of males and females
so lean individuals but not shredded
and the the total amount of weight loss
going on here was
three three and a half kilograms and so
when i look at these results i don't
look at them and say wow this is a huge
impact of refeeds but i also look at
them and say
why would i necessarily expect refeeds
to have a huge impact uh in this
particular application you know if we're
not talking about shredded and we're not
talking about huge weight loss
i just don't know if there's enough
adaptation there to be really
intervening to reverse it you know
now there's uh the ice cap trial by
jackson pios and colleagues
um
same kind of deal where uh you know
they're looking at a group with an
average body fat percentage of 25
this was a mixed sample males and
females
and what they were looking at here
was uh i believe it was three weeks of
dieting and then one week of a diet
break in the diet break group and then
of course
the uh
the non-diet break group the continuous
weight loss group uh you know they just
went straight through for the entire
duration of the trial uh which was they
ended up both groups were uh in a
calorie deficit for 12 weeks and they
both had the same deficit uh it's just
the
diet break group had that kind of broken
up every every fourth week with with
maintenance
um
basically what they found here uh
no differences when it came to fat loss
fat-free mass uh
looked at a bunch of other stuff uh
muscle strength uh muscle endurance
resting energy expenditure leptin
testosterone
sleep eating disorder behaviors there's
a lot of outcomes that they looked at
and the diet breaks didn't seem to do
much
uh the main thing that they found was
that uh
it did have a small effect uh reducing
appetite so adding the diet breaks
favorably affected appetite in this
particular application
this was once again a situation where
the individuals of the study were
you know healthy athletic folks uh
but they were not like shredded this
wasn't like looking at physique athletes
and the overall magnitude of of weight
loss was not particularly large it's
again we're talking in the in the
ballpark of a few kilograms in total
uh and then finally there was uh kind of
a secondary analysis from that same
icecap trial by uh jackson piazza
colleagues and this actually came out in
2021 it came out a handful of months ago
i think
but they were looking at what actually
happens over the course of that one week
diet break
so they looked at the final diet break
in the series of diet breaks
and uh
they they did notice that when you look
from the beginning of the diet break to
the end over that one week period there
was improved muscle endurance uh in the
legs there was increased mental
alertness and reduced appetite and
reduced irritability uh so you could say
even within the broader context of that
trial there were not noteworthy
effects when it came to body composition
performance things like that
you could at least say in the short term
you know from the beginning of the diet
break to the end these folks were pretty
happy you know there were some nice
things there when it comes to appetite
performance uh irritability things like
that so
not bad but but nothing that's gonna
really change the trajectory of you know
a short-term intervention yeah and and
more importantly than the actual results
of the study i would say
uh have you seen pictures of jackson
recently
uh i have
he's looking [ __ ] big
yeah and that's really all you need to
know right yeah yeah i would
when big people say stuff you just kind
of do what they say yeah yeah absolutely
um no jackson's cool i was uh i was
messaging with him this morning about
the study just getting some
clarification
he's awesome smart dude uh really on top
of it yeah yeah yeah i uh this is this
is completely uh off the rails but um
yeah his his profile picture for a long
time was just like him in a hat and an
under armour hoodie yeah and uh you know
i i'm not one to judge a book by its
cover but i was like yeah you know seems
looks looks like a personal trainer type
guy seems fairly bright based on what
i've seen him posting around the
internet uh and just recently some some
progress pics of him uh popped up on my
timeline i was just like
jesus christ dude like why didn't you
lead with that yeah
[ __ ] big so he wanted you to take his
research seriously not treat him like a
meat head no i i understand and
appreciate that but uh yeah jackson if
if you listen to the podcast good work
man yeah
uh so one additional study to uh to talk
about
and this is the best one by a wide
margin uh the most important the most
well done
totally unrelated i helped with it um
but
i'm giving you i'm giving you an
objective assessment uh no i'm totally
kidding uh
pretty much everybody that's doing this
research uh you know i i know people
on all these papers and they're it's
just a bunch of good
good folks good researchers who really
want to get to the bottom of this stuff
it's a fascinating line of research
this particular study is not yet
published in paper form but the
abstracts are out there which is why i'm
you know comfortable talking about the
results
but it's by seidler and colleagues out
of bill campbell's lab at usf
this particular study
recruited 38 resistance trained females
and basically it was a 25 reduction in
caloric intake to establish the deficit
and it was you know one group did six
weeks straight of dieting the other did
two weeks of dieting one week of a diet
break two one two one two so everybody
um what was uh you know had the same
deficit but one one group had that kind
of pattern of diet breaks
now
looked at physiological outcomes quite a
few related to body composition resting
metabolic rate things of that nature
really nothing nothing notable to report
there
no meaningful statistically significant
outcomes there
there was reduced eating disinhibitions
so disinhibition is a loss of control
over eating so uh the fact that diet
breaks decreased eating disinhibition
was a positive thing um you know
but that was was pretty much it when we
looked at a pretty broad range of
physiological outcomes and also outcomes
related to eating behaviors that was the
single kind of sub scale that was you
know statistically significant and
did did go in favor of implementing
periodic diet breaks
so
i think this is a critically important
point and i've already alluded to it
previously but when you look at the diet
break and the refeed literature
and you say
do i need it
i think these are interventions that are
highly
specialized they are targeted
interventions that have specific applica
like if you're talking about
physiological stuff they have very
specific applications that in my opinion
my hunch
is that they have uh
much
i think they make much more sense in
context where there's a very substantial
magnitude of weight loss
or the individuals are absolutely
shredded now we don't have enough
evidence to put it in a huge
meta-analysis and say well let's look at
the little section of 12 studies and
shredded people right they don't exist
yeah we don't have the studies where we
can say let's do a
you know a meta regression and look at
the change in body weight and see you
know how the effect changes uh you know
across that spectrum there's not enough
data to look at it and
quantitatively you know
really
confidently assert like this absolutely
is going to have a huge impact in these
specific areas but if you look at the
limited data available
and you use a little bit of theory
behind it
i see the most application for these
types of interventions in those specific
contexts now
that doesn't mean you can't use it in
other contexts you know you might be
someone who
uh just because of convenience you like
to have a refeed or too uh or
you enjoy what it brings you in the gym
when you know you have some extra carbs
and some extra calories before a big leg
day
or you know if it's your social calendar
it fits your training calendar uh
it fits whatever preference you like you
know that you you absolutely based on
the data we've seen
can apply
a diet break or a refeed strategy and
feel pretty confident that you're going
to be looking at
no major downside and potential for some
upsides with uh subjective outcomes of
like you know
how how your appetite feels maybe uh
just some more positive affect um there
could be some psychological benefits
there could be some adherence related
benefits um the only clear downside that
you could really uh hold against these
strategies would be
that you're you're losing time right so
there are a lot there are some people
who if you told them hey we're going to
increase you know the
like let's say you want to do the
matador type intervention right two
weeks on two weeks off
there are a lot of people who if you
said hey do you want to diet for like 16
weeks or like 32 weeks they'd be like
yeah i just want to do it for 16 weeks
and get it over with you know so
i think there's a lot of room there to
accommodate personal preferences but
i think one of the reasons i wanted to
revisit this topic is because the
physiology is cool
and there is more data so it's
worthwhile to revisit that
and
my official
perspective on it is that i still think
these are interesting strategies for for
very specific applications
but
when you look at the studies
like campbell like pios like sedler and
colleagues
when we're looking at fairly moderate
body fat ranges and we're looking at
fairly modest magnitudes of weight loss
we're talking about a few kilograms here
and there
we're not seeing huge physiological
effects in many cases we're not seeing
physiological effects really at all
when it comes to body composition and
metabolic rate
um
so
these are interventions or strategies
that are certainly on the table
certainly usable but by no means uh
mandatory you know i've working with
one-on-one clients i have some clients
that use them
because it fits their preferences and
you know it makes sense in certain
applications but the vast majority of my
clients do not use diet breaks or
refeeds aside from just like hey i'm
going on vacation i don't want to be on
a diet you know and then we talk about
some strategies
when i diet i don't use refeeds or diet
breaks like for for bodybuilding
competitions for a very
nuanced reason being i don't feel like
it
and
i like to just get where i'm going and
it's fine uh because you will find some
people
like me
who uh i'll be like dude i was used to
my
awful diet with low calories that was
boring
when i get a day or two days or a week
of like hey do you remember what food
was like
you know remember like carbohydrate
that doesn't do good things for me uh if
for me it's much easier psychologically
to just lock in and be like this is what
it is
no i mean that makes sense one of the
things that always uh
that always amuses me on social media is
when someone is
clearly getting close to the end of a
pretty aggressive cut either they're
just trying to lose a fair bit of weight
or they're trying to get super lean
and
maybe like a month or two before the end
of their cut
they start posting recipe content and
it's just like look i figured out a way
to make brownies out of protein powder
and i swear to god they're as good as
real brownies and then like a month
after when they're you know starting to
eat normal food again they'll be like
guys i just had a real brownie i i lied
to you a couple months ago those
brownies [ __ ] sucked uh so i mean
like that's that's that's a very fair
point i feel like uh
if you can forget what good food tastes
like
and maybe that could help you so this is
a completely serious example
uh you might know what i'm gonna say
i
i really believed
deep down in my heart
that pb2
[Music]
[Laughter]
mixed with water
was
fully indistinguishable from from peanut
butter
and actually i think i made the argument
a few times that it was actually
preferable
when you
balance the flavor and the consistency i
i believe i argued on behalf of pb2
being a
calories aside a more enjoyable dietary
option than regular peanut butter
on an unrelated note i hadn't had peanut
butter in like a year
uh and then i had peanut butter and
i was blown away and i had to call a lot
of people and apologize uh
and correct a lot of statements but uh
but no like so
these are strategies that in certain
applications make sense uh based on a
physiological rationale you've also made
uh yeah and i think
we both know what i'm about to say
you've made similarly bizarre claims
about certain styles of lasagna uh well
no i stand by well i
i think you
you've actually been meaning to uh
to recant some lasagna related
statements that you've made previously
but
we can move on yeah i'm not there yet
um
so
is there room in the fitness world for
these strategies yes
but one of the things i try to be really
cautious about when i discuss them is
making sure that i'm not over promising
i i don't want to hype these things up
uh if you come to me and you're like you
know what i've been prepping for a
bodybuilding show for 34 weeks uh i'm
shredded my calories are so low and i
feel very bad
does a diet break make sense i'd say
yeah
let's give that a shot right but you
know if you're
cutting you know i'm just going to use
male numbers for ease here but
if you're cutting from 19 body fat to 16
body fat
and uh taking it nice and slow and
steady
and you're like how much am i missing
out on by not having diet breaks or
refeeds like
probably nothing
from a physiological perspective
so i don't like to over promise i don't
like to hype these things up i think a
lot of people because they're
fascinating from a physiological
perspective and because
one of the potential applications that
theoretically make sense there's a lack
of data but theoretically it makes sense
to see these used in people who are
shredded you know some of the best
physiques on the planet
when it's a strategy used by the people
with the best physiques i think that
kind of inherently
feeds into that hype right of like
i see this correlation here everybody
who looks like you know a fitness model
seems to be doing it yeah uh maybe i
ought to give that a shot which is
understandable logic
uh but yeah so i i don't like to over
hype them i don't like to talk them up
too much
they
might have some potential in certain
situations they're certainly never a
disastrous choice to make but one of the
reasons i bring this up is people have
asked a little bit like
now that macro factor is out the diet
app
they'll ask you know
what kind of cheat code do i need to put
in to unlock the refeed mode you know
like we don't have dedicated modes of
operation where we say hey give me the
the secret you know give me the good
stuff give me the diet breaks
the reason we don't have that is because
well there's two reasons one don't want
to over hype them
because for the majority of people
in most contexts they're not going to be
tremendously impactful physiologically
number two
they're so easily achieved without a
dedicated mode of operation
it would just serve to make the app
unnecessarily more complex to navigate
so
if you are using macro factor and you
say i want to do a diet break
very easy to make that happen if you're
using it you say i want to do a
refeeding strategy once again
tremendously easy to make that happen on
collaborative mode
and you can specifically choose how much
am i increasing my calories how much of
that's coming from carbohydrate am i
doing it tuesday and friday am i doing
it friday and saturday uh
there's so much flexibility there it's
it's very easily done so so that that
kind of clears up people have been
wondering did you guys forget that
refeeds and diet breaks exist definitely
not
we just didn't want to give them their
own separate you didn't
i did it yeah
didn't want to give them their own
separate mode of operation but they are
totally doable
uh if you're curious about them there's
no harm in trying them out but uh from a
lot of people wonder am i missing out by
not having them and the answer is
probably not
and that is what we call a segway in the
entertainment business because we've got
a tech support segment we do we do have
a tech support segment a new segment on
the podcast first time we did it was
last episode
and really if you've been spending time
in the macro factor facebook group or
subreddit uh
you know what this tech support segment
is going to be about
people love the app but there is
one and only one relatively consistent
complaint about it uh primarily from
people outside of the us
uh and that is uh questions and
complaints about the database we use um
i had every intention of writing an
article about this or writing writing an
article that was just kind of like
faqs about about the app in general
and this was going to be included but
then uh then mass time rolled around and
so
you know i figured this is worth
discussing and i figure it's worth
not waiting another two weeks to discuss
so yeah going to talk about it on the
podcast as a tech support segment um
so yeah uh the the basic question is
you know what database are we using and
why did we choose it uh even though
like product and barcode coverage
is somewhat spotty uh outside of the us
so to start with i i want to first start
by
uh addressing
the most negative implication i think
that often comes along with complaints
about the database and that's that uh
like some people have either implied or
just stayed up or just straight up uh
stated that
we're
kind of typical jingoistic americans and
don't care about the world outside of
the us borders
and like honestly that's fair i
understand that uh
you know if you've met
too many americans of certain stripes
that's it's not a uh a completely
unreasonable assumption to start with uh
but no that that does not uh describe us
first um
you can see it in our in the history of
how we've done business previously so
the stronger by science program bundle
uh is very cheap it's uh it's ten bucks
launched at five bucks um
and i i think it's for what it is it's
uh
i think it's the cheapest
type of product of its kind that you can
buy uh and and
one of the major reasons that i made it
so cheap um was just because i would get
a lot of messages particularly on
instagram from people from lower income
countries um you know saying like hey
what are what are some good programs
that are out there that i could run and
i'd make some suggestions and they'd be
like oh that's like 30 bucks that's like
50 bucks 70 bucks whatever uh you know
that
that's like a month's pay for me that's
uh that's ludicrous like i'm sure it's a
good program but i can't afford it um so
i mean one of the major reasons i made
my program so cheap was just so that
there could be
premium options on the market that would
be accessible to
like more of the global lifting
community
um so yeah i mean that that's something
that that is always in mind um
you know i i'm fully aware that the
world doesn't end uh at the borders of
the us and also uh if we did only care
about our us audience that would just be
a bad business move um i know our
analytics about 40 of our audience is
from the us
uh and so
i think that implies that about 60 is
from outside the u.s uh so yeah
obviously we we care about uh everyone
else
so um
with with that out of the way uh you
know the basic question is why
did we go
the direction we went with with our
database
and uh
i mean the the basic answer to that
question is that when you start looking
around at what databases are available
to integrate with um
the the pickings are a bit slimmer than
i think people would immediately assume
um so like for example a lot of people
have suggested like well why don't you
just integrate with myfitnesspals
database or
like a fair number of germans have
messaged me saying like well why don't
you integrate with yazio's database uh
and the thing is like we would [ __ ]
love to do that that would be sick um
they simply aren't options though uh
their their business is their database
and allowing other people to access it
um would remove a lot of their
competitive advantage so yeah if we
could get access to databases like that
we would love to and that that would uh
that would be something that we would
jump on but those those simply aren't
options that were available out of the
gate um so
there was a pretty long research process
mainly headed up by one of the
developers corey
where he did a ton of research on what
avail of what databases are actually
available to either
integrate with via api or to license
and
the two best by far were fat secret and
nutrition x
there are other databases out there
that
are
are decent but in terms of of a day one
database to start with those were the
two best uh by by a pretty substantial
margin
um
and they they have their pros and cons
so um one of the things that our current
uk and australia macro factory users
have have asked is they've asked about
this in particular like other people
who've looked into databases
and they say like look you guys are
using nutritionx um
we have
uh you know not wonderful but
considerably better product support from
the fat secret database so why didn't
you go with that to start with um and
there were a few reasons for it
one is that
if we went with fat secret that would
have improved our product and barcode
database on day one
for
particularly users from from the uk and
australia but the thing is both
nutrition x and fat secret are
uh
are pretty trash outside of
us canada uh uk and australia so like
ultimately our goal is to have
excellent global support for everyone um
you know as it is now
we serve about five percent of the
global population very well and about 95
percent quite poorly if we went with fat
secret we would have served uh you know
maybe six and a half percent of the
global population really well and ninety
three and a half percent quite poorly um
so yeah for for uk and australia or for
for users from the uk and australia
uh fat secret from the jump would have
improved things for you personally but
it wouldn't have fundamentally
improved our our global coverage all
that much
um
so that that would have been an
advantage of fat secret but there are um
pretty substantial advantages for
starting with nutrition x
two of the biggest ones that i think our
users
feel the most
is one the nutritionx api offerings are
just a lot better so
one of the features a lot of people like
and one of the features we like for
marketing purposes just because it's
very cool
is the ai describe function where you
can you know push a button talk into
your mic say like
i want
200 grams of potatoes and a tablespoon
of butter or whatever and it will pull
those things up for you
it's very slick it's very cool works
quite well
and that's a that's a nutrition x
offering that's not a feature that we
developed
and going with the nutritionx api
enabled that for us um
so that that's like a neat little bell
and whistle the other
i think considerably more important
factor uh for going with nutritionx
is
fat secret
functionally doesn't have my
micronutrient support
i think it i think it reports fiber i
think it reports sodium
i think it might report alcohol uh but
you know if you want to get into
any sort of like relatively in-depth
micronutrient tracking
uh
fat secret is
severely lacking for that um
and that's one of the things that a lot
of
our users are into like we have a fair
number of macro factor users who are
coming from chronometer um
and our our micronutrient support isn't
quite as good as chronometers uh because
that's
the one thing they they focus on they
are far and away the market leader for
that
uh but i i think that we're
um
i think that it's very
feasible for us to target number two in
the in the micronutrient tracking market
in addition to to being better than
chronometer several other things um and
so anyway uh
that's something that nutritionx does
for us that fat secret wouldn't have and
the other thing is like i said for the
the product and barcode support fat
secret would have been a little bit
better for the uk and australia
um but the nutritionx database has an
excellent
generic foods and in the app they're
labeled common foods it has an excellent
generic foods library um
which i think fat secret does have one
as well but it's not nearly as good and
again doesn't uh contain nearly as much
micronutrient information um
so essentially where we provide
excellent barcode and product support to
the us and canada
and then via the common foods database
from nutritionx we still provide pretty
decent support to everyone else
it's not quite as convenient as scanning
a barcode but most of the foods that
you'd be eating would be in the common
foods database
so you know it was basically a question
of do we provide excellent support to
five percent
and pretty decent support to the other
95 percent or do we provide
good to excellent support for seven
percent in pretty shitty support for the
other 93
and we went with option a so
um
yeah
to be clear i do understand why some
people from the uk and australia might
be a little bit frustrated uh but we
weren't just trying to hang you out to
dry
a tough choice needed to be made and we
think that the nutritionx database
did offer
considerable benefits that just weren't
present in fat secret
and
the most important thing
is that
we never intended for the nutrition x
database to be our only database
offering
so this is
i think where
um
[Music]
yeah so so this i think will be the
answer to the question of you know
what's going on with our current
databases and and how do how do we want
to improve it um i think this is kind of
the question that people have have been
wanting us to answer
um
so yeah nutritionx was basically
uh it was a good day one option because
it had api support and what that means
is essentially we can pay per user so
there was a chance that macro factor was
just going to be a dud that we'd launch
it and people would say like oh i'm
happy with the app that i'm currently
using i don't
feel the need to uh
to to get this new app uh and
you know so
if if the launch wouldn't have gone have
gone well uh
being able to pay per user would be
incredibly clutch because essentially
that would mean that we wouldn't have
risked uh in ending up just losing a ton
of money um
however
there are other databases that you you
don't just integrate with via api and
pay per user per database query
there are other databases out there that
you can license
which essentially means instead of
paying per user you just pay
you just write a pretty fat check up
front
and then generally have to pay like a
flat rate yearly
which would have involved taking on a
ton of risk before we launched the app
in the first place
but there are some databases like that
that will allow us to expand our
coverage uh throughout the rest of the
world and so
um
with that in mind i'm not going to say
what it is yet but we do have a database
in mind
that we are actively doing research on
in fact just this past week
i put out a call in the facebook group
and subreddit and uh about 300 people
have been going out around the world
testing out this new database for us
i've been i've been gathering the
feedback and collating it uh and so
i'm not gonna say what it is yet but
what i will say
is that uh the results are in and the
picture it paints is pretty clear
uh so
we already have excellent support for
the us and canada
adding this new database
will give us
very very good support
in the uk
ireland australia
uh new zealand
and
the rest of the world let's just say
it's it's mixed uh to to put it um
to put it politely so
for european users for example uh one
person from malta randomly had great
luck with it
a few people from norway and finland
have had good luck with it um but
in that same general part of the world
people from sweden and denmark have had
very bad results with it um
but anyway it will be
an enormous improvement for people from
the uk ireland australia new zealand and
will probably be
a small improvement for
uh for people elsewhere
um
so
to be clear uh
we never
we
so we're going we're approaching macro
factor with
a pretty long-term road map in mind uh
the the product support that you're
currently experiencing with with the app
is our day one product support um
but our intention is and has always been
to provide excellent product and barcode
support
uh globally
um and it's just that you know
because the product wasn't on the market
yet we were just limited in terms of
what we could offer on day one uh but we
are
currently in the in the research and
planning stages for uh improving that
substantially for a pretty good chunk of
our users i don't want to commit to a
timeline yet but but relatively soon
um and our our plan is to get there for
everyone
in the meantime
um
in the meantime uh just to circle back
uh i mentioned that nutritionx has
excellent has an excellent common foods
library i think it's like
15 16 000 foods give or take and these
are like staple products so you know
various meats various grains fruits
vegetables dairy products etc
most of the just kind of like
basic foods that people eat around the
world
are in the nutritionx common foods
library
and those are the foods that have the
best
overall uh nutrition reporting so
um
if you're someone who does like to track
micronutrients or you know let's say
you're a vegetarian or vegan and you
want to make sure you're getting uh all
of your essential amino acids and just
all of the amino acids period
you would need to be logging common
foods anyways because
branded products like products you'd
find by scanning a barcode generally
have pretty bad micronutrient reporting
and that's not a nutrition x drawback
that's just a
a regulations drawback
the government doesn't require
say tyson's tyson foods to report all of
the micronutrients and every chicken
product it sells but the just standard
chicken entries in the nutritionx common
foods database do have that information
uh so
you know like i said nutritionx has a
has a good common foods library that's
already what you would need to be
logging if you want a good micronutrient
support
and that's personally how i use the app
already
i would say i open the barcode scanner
on my app
maybe once a week uh and it's always
just to scan different energy drinks i
don't know why i never use the barcode
scanner for anything except when i go to
the gas station and get an energy drink
for whatever reason when i want to log
that i just always go to the barcode
scanner for it which is weird uh i have
no idea why that behavior pattern exists
i do
why
at that point you're so depleted of
energy oh like i i couldn't even fathom
typing in a few letters so that it will
show up in my search history that might
be true
um
but anyway uh i like to imagine you're
kind of just like crawling up to the
counter with it like please
give me this drink yeah that's pretty
accurate um
anyway all of which is to say if you
live somewhere that the nutritionx
database doesn't currently cover with
barcode and branded product support uh
or if you live somewhere
that uh when we add this new database
into the mix if you still live somewhere
where you still won't have
excellent uh branded product and barcode
support
your experience with macro factor is
still virtually identical to mine um and
you know what i did i hadn't planned on
doing this but i'm gonna i'm gonna do
something a little bit crazy on air uh
on a hot mic
until we add this next database into the
mix i will not use the barcode scanner
in macro factor that that again to be
clear that's a very small sacrifice
because i basically never use it in the
first place uh but until we get this new
database added
my experience with the app will be
identical to your experience with the
app um
that that is a pledge that that i feel
incredibly comfortable making to
everyone out there um
because yeah i mean
we
there are already a lot of little bells
and whistles in macro factor that make
it pretty convenient to log food even if
you never open the barcode scanner uh
the common foods uh library is very good
um
the smart history is very good like
that's one thing to note if you
use the barcode scanner can't find
anything and you're just like ah this is
a waste of my time i'm gonna log in some
other app and port my data over
i would recommend just giving it a shot
for a week or two the smart history in
macro factor really is
just insanely convenient if you keep a
pretty standard schedule and eat
you know
a
small to moderate variety of foods over
time uh pretty often you'll just go into
the food logger your smart history will
already be pulled up those are foods
that you commonly eat around a
particular time of day and you just
click on it like you don't you don't
even have to search for anything once
you get a once you've used the app for a
week or two and you have a pretty well
populated smart history uh there would
be no no need to even open up
the the barcode scanner in the first
place because most of the stuff you'd be
looking for is just sitting right there
for you to tap on it and then there's
good copy and paste features very quick
very seamless um
so yeah i mean independent of never
using the barcode scanner i barely even
use the search bar because
you know i i would say
maybe five times a week i consume
something that's not already in my smart
history and i i do uh eat from a
relatively small pool of foods um and i
do
pretty heavy meal prepping so i'm you
know using the search bar quite a bit on
sunday while i'm cooking a big batch of
food and then i can just go to my
recipes and that's that's mostly what
i'm logging from throughout the week um
but yeah i mean
what i would say and i'm sure this comes
across as a sales pitch but i swear to
god this is how i use the app myself um
you you can you can get a long way and
have a pretty seamless food logging
experience without ever worrying about
the barcode or branded products database
and to be clear
if
if your preferred
mode of interaction with a tracking app
is to be able to scan barcodes i
completely understand that and i'm not
saying
i don't use that therefore you should
not expect it um
you know like we we want to meet the
needs of everyone using the app and if
that is how you prefer to interact with
a food tracking app uh we have every
intention of delivering that to you uh
but for the time being like
just give it a shot for a week or two
use the search bar use the common foods
get your smart history populated
i think you'll be pleasantly surprised
at
how comfortable the food logging
experience is already even if we don't
have a good barcode database in in your
neck of the woods
yeah between the copy and paste feature
and the smart history feature i i never
use the barcode uh but one caveat or
warning i guess about the smart history
feature is that
it will hold up a mirror and teach you
things about yourself that cannot be
unseen
uh there have been a couple
a couple instances of people who open up
the app at two in the morning and it's
like
i want some ice cream and they're like
no
i was gonna have carrots but
i mean yeah maybe i'll have some ice
cream yeah but yeah it kind of knows
like what time of day what you're going
for
um but no i mean the smart history and
the copy paste are really clutch yeah
yeah my
my smart history at like 10 11 that's
that's generally around the time i'm
eating my first meal of the day so it's
just like hey do you want to
eat the thing that you've meal prepped
recently and it's like yes macro factor
i do thank you and then around 4 30 it's
like oh hey
uh you're probably eating a snack before
you go play basketball do you want to
eat the things you typically snack on to
fuel up for basketball it's like yeah
thanks i i do i very much like that
uh then around dinner time it's like hey
you know you eat
uh pretty consistently about four
various meats and
three or four carb sources and five or
six vegetables i just scroll down the
list like tap what you're eating for
dinner tonight and uh
you know you'll be good to go i'm like
thank you that's that's exactly what i
needed and then i'm working late at
night and uh you know i'm
gonna eat a snack at like 3 a.m
and
maybe i've already gotten the snack and
maybe it's something that that's
perfectly healthy i'm eating an apple or
whatever i don't know
but i open up the app i go to add
something to the plate it's like do you
want cookies do you want ice cream uh
do you do you want to eat two cups of
craisins
i'm like
not this time but
but i i appreciate the offer um
but yeah no it's
if you so okay here's what i'll say
if you do eat
a super wide variety of foods like if
you go back and look at what you ate in
the past week and you consumed
um i don't know like
50 or 60 different discreet food
products
i i could very much understand why
branded product and barcode support
would matter quite a bit more
especially if if you know you're eating
40 different food products within a
single meal slot
such that you wouldn't be going back to
a lot of the same things fairly
consistently for your smart history um
yeah i mean if your if your breakfasts
often look fairly similar and your
lunches often look fairly similar i
think a lot of people have more variety
at dinners
but yeah
smart
i swear to god the smart history works
so well
i think for the vast majority of people
two meals out of the day
you want you won't even need to tap the
search bar much less the uh
much less the barcode scanner once that
smart history gets populated so
if you can deal with a little bit of
friction for a week or two um i i really
do think the food logging experience is
already
pretty darn good for the vast majority
of people um but
you know to bring to bring us back to
where this tech support segment started
especially for people in the uk
australia ireland new zealand uh the the
branded product and barcode support uh
in the not too distant future is going
to get a lot lot better yeah cool
all right we are a bit behind schedule
i'm going to do my q a rapid fire let's
do it q a segment you guys ask questions
uh and we give answers to the best of
our abilities so i've got a question
from kevin
we've got a scenario on vacation not
doing structured exercise
how bad could weight gain slash muscle
loss be
if i act like a degenerate for two weeks
um
and so there's basically two questions
here uh talking about a two week time
frame muscle loss and also
weight gain or specifically fat gain if
it's happening in the context of muscle
loss
when it comes to the muscle loss uh one
to two weeks really is not a big deal a
significant appreciable muscle loss
really shouldn't occur
over that one to two week time frame
uh as long as you're not like
immobilized or on complete bed rest uh
you know if you're going about your
day-to-day activities
one to two weeks is not a timeline that
i would be super concerned about uh
once we start getting to the like two to
three three to four week time frame then
i start to say okay now we might want to
talk about some pretty uh proactive
mitigation strategies to to make sure
that we're maintaining as much muscle
mass as we can
so what might that strategy be
not just over feeding protein
the research is pretty consistent uh
just bumping up your protein over a
vacation if you're not actually loading
your muscles
is not going to save you from muscle
loss
[Music]
if anything your protein needs could
potentially be a little bit lower since
you're not training but usually i just
try to keep my protein pretty stable in
this type of scenario there are some
studies indicating that like really high
dose leucine might be slightly helpful
uh but
i wouldn't hold my breath on that one uh
the evidence is mixed the effect sizes
are not particularly large so uh the
strategy really isn't dieting in this in
this scenario when it comes to retaining
muscle uh if you're talking about you
know three four weeks or longer uh it's
important to recognize a little bit of
resistance training goes a very long way
we're talking about body weight stuff if
you can sneak a couple bands in your
travel bag
very basic stuff even if you don't have
gym access should go a very long way and
it doesn't have to be high volume if you
keep the intensity up you know either
doing high loads if they're
if they're available or just pushing
relatively close to failure with body
weight and band type stuff you don't
have to spend two hours a day doing this
stuff low volume but putting in the
effort uh should be a good way to go
when it comes to fat gain uh
i mean
to to gain a a considerable amount of
fat like if you're trying to gain a
kilogram of fat assuming that there's no
adaptive increase in total daily energy
expenditure from over feeding and there
very well might be orders from being on
vacation and walking around doing
vacation stuff yeah so your total daily
energy expenditure very well could go up
in this uh situation but even if it
didn't we're talking about over 9 000
calories of a surplus to store a new
kilogram of fat
um
so i mean if you're going way overboard
with your caloric intake i mean no doubt
some degree of fat accumulation can
occur
but it's nothing that can't be undone
after the vacation's over and the
likelihood of you know several kilograms
of fat mass gain uh quite implausible
within this type of time frame
um so my typical guidance uh
by the way your weight will likely
fluctuate quite a bit uh especially if
you're you're kind of really exploring a
lot of different food options and
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that eating is one of my favorite things
about vacations
but there's a lot of water weight
fluctuation uh you know changing your
food schedule changing your food
environment
different amount of just bulk material
in the gi tract different amount of
sodium and carbohydrate a lot of water
fluctuations but
you know in terms of fat gain probably
not too much
accumulation there my typical guidance
though uh when i work with one-on-one
clients who are about to go on a one or
two week trip
uh we basically set a spectrum with two
anchors uh so on one end of the spectrum
the really strict end of the spectrum we
say oh let's keep our diet exactly the
same no accommodations hit the same
targets weigh things the same way you
normally do or track things the same way
you normally do no change at all the
other end of the spectrum is
we're not just going off the diet we are
intentionally
aggressively indulging you know we are
really
just exploring every culinary option
and just over feeding on a very
consistent basis
no targets no tracking no moderation you
know
if there's a hedonic occasion to eat
go for it you know past the point of
fullness now we rarely choose either of
those options that sets the spectrum and
then we talk about a variety of
different options that fall between
those ends of the spectrum so
we could
keep macro targets as a strategy but we
could increase the targets from where
they're currently at we could keep a
calorie target and a protein minimum but
say hey as long as you're kind of close
to these calories and getting at least
this much protein you're good to go we
could not track at all but say hey focus
on
you know food selection and meal
composition so when you sit down for a
meal where's my protein where's my
fibrous vegetable arrange a plate and
kind of focus on it that way
one thing i'll do
is i'll say pick one meal per day where
we're really going to loosen up so you
know keep things pretty uh pretty tight
with breakfast and lunch and then dinner
will be the big meal where we really
relax a little bit
uh a similar strategy prioritize the
areas where you want to indulge right so
if you want to go out for drinks one
night you know if i'm on vacation trying
to be mindful of my diet i'll say you
know what tonight i am having a few
alcoholic beverages so i might keep my
entree you know a little bit leaner you
know go with
lean you know fish and vegetables and
maybe a little starch and then save up
some calories so that i can have a
little more alcohol or you know you
could say i'm gonna
go a little lighter on the entree
because i really like a dessert that i
have my eye on or vice versa i'm gonna
skip dessert because i you know see this
particular entree that has caught my eye
so
there are a tremendous number of dietary
strategies that you could choose ranging
from very restrictive to very flexible
and what i do with my clients is i talk
through a pretty broad
variety of these and we figure out based
on the context of the trip what would be
the most sensible solution
the next one next question uh from adam
thoughts on high sodium for strength
sports
um this has become pretty popular a lot
of people
going a little higher with their sodium
intake hoping for some performance
improvements
the rda or the recommended intake in the
states last time i checked i think was
like to keep it under 2300 milligrams a
day so under like 2.3 grams a day seems
very plausible uh and it's very clear
why that's set hypertension is prevalent
uh some people are pretty salt sensitive
you know when salt or sodium goes up in
their diet blood pressure tends to
increase a little bit and so
you know the recommended intake is
largely focused on
trying to manage
hypertension rates in the segment of the
population that is a little bit
sensitive to dietary sodium now
the rda is not necessarily for optimal
performance for athletes and that's
something we always have to consider
we do lose sodium when we sweat
so
higher salt intakes may be tolerated
well by some athletes and in some cases
might actually be
necessary so not just well tolerated but
actually beneficial uh depending on you
know your rate of sweat sweat loss the
concentration of your sweat which does
vary
um
and so the reason that this is important
for athletes is because
sufficient sodium levels help us
maintain plasma volume
uh help encourage us to continue
drinking fluids
so sometimes you'll see in sport
nutrition strategies they'll add some
sodium to the sports beverage not
because you necessarily need sodium
replacement but because they want you to
continue having the thirst response and
continue drinking more and more fluid
throughout the
doesn't it also just hydrate you a
little bit faster though yeah yeah it
does but but sometimes the uh
they'll specifically kind of highlight
uh that extra sodium i mean it
absolutely it does help hydrate you a
little bit more than just a water
solution
so there are multifaceted benefits but
for there's a lot of athletes who will
dehydrate themselves because they just
don't feel like drinking water and so a
nice sports beverage with some sodium
and some sugar and things like that it
tastes good it encourages that thirst
response and the fact that it also
hydrates them better is like oh terrific
but we really just need them to keep
coming back for more cups of beverage
you know
so uh anyway
absolutely maintaining sufficient sodium
levels uh and drinking a sodium
beverage during uh particular types of
exercise can be a good strategy for uh
replacing the sodium that's lost from
sweat encouraging thirst response and
more fluid intake and maintaining
hydration but
um this is particularly important when
it comes to
exercise that involves high sweat rates
so if you're lifting in a climate
controlled gym
probably doesn't matter a ton depending
on how much you typically sweat and how
hot it is in the gym um now if you're in
like a you know if it's like a ronnie
coleman training video from back in the
day
uh texas right yeah so you're you know
in the middle of texas it's july he
trained at metroflex houston
yeah so if it's if it's july and houston
and there's no air conditioner
yeah
you're probably losing some sweat
probably losing some sodium uh so some
degree of replacement might might be
warranted there but when we talk about
the idea of sodium and actually
enhancing performance
the only studies where i've seen that
really happen is
performance of tasks in situations where
uh hydration status is truly threatening
performance so
uh if if you're doing an endurance type
exercise that involves high cardiac
output it's in the heat it's prolonged
duration those are instances where you
might find a performance benefit if
you're comparing a water solution to
a solution with some degree of sodium in
it
now it is true mechanistically that
sodium plays a role in muscle
contraction
but
uh
we got to pause before we say therefore
more sodium more contraction very strong
the body has very robust mechanisms to
maintain stability within a certain
range when it comes to blood sodium
levels
and that's because sodium and potassium
are
very important
so that that's not the type of thing
that your body likes to lose track of um
and you know of course with
really substantial with great enough
sodium losses at some point those
mechanisms could be unable to maintain
appropriate levels of sodium and
potassium but well i mean the the same
uh
the same sodium and potassium related uh
like mechanisms of um
like muscle membrane depolarization
that's the same thing that goes on with
like nerve depolarization so
as long as your nerves work your muscles
are probably going to work
just fine yeah you should at least like
with regards to to electrolyte balance
yeah you do want your nerves working
yeah
always correct when possible um
so like you know there was a study by
the general point here is if your sodium
levels in your blood are getting low
enough that muscle contraction is being
impacted
you are screwed yeah that is not a good
spot to be
uh so it's not that you know the lifter
i i mean
i don't even know that you would get
there this this is complete speculation
i haven't thought about it that much
but uh i mean like
endurance athletes that die of
hyponatremia are
aren't they generally still running when
their brain swells up and they die
i don't know i mean i i
i think their muscles are still
functioning well enough to keep them
moving
while their sodium levels are
from a nervous system perspective
already
dangerously dangerously low yeah so i i
kind of think that
if sodium levels are already low enough
that they're affecting muscle
contractility
you got a big [ __ ] problem on your
hands yeah and
you probably will have noticed it
already because you'll
i mean you'll be getting delirious yeah
so i did find a study looking at this uh
title was impact of hyponatremia on
nerve conduction and muscle strength by
vander geinst
and colleagues um
chronic mild to moderate hyponatremia
like clinical hyponatremia uh did not
have an impact on muscle strength within
that study and these were not
particularly healthy folks within this
study um so
the the overall
conclusion here
uh
it's not that you know taking a big
spoonful of sodium is going to
supercharge your workout or anything
like that
that would not be an accurate
representation of the data that i've
seen personally always always open to
reviewing new studies that i may not be
aware of of course
but the general idea is you just want to
keep your your sodium and potassium
levels within
uh healthy viable ranges and it usually
doesn't take a tremendous amount of
effort to do that
if you are
exercising and losing a lot of sweat and
your sweat has particularly high
concentrations of sodium a little bit of
sodium replacement might not be a
terrible idea
but i probably don't need a super
nuanced
deliberate strategy to do any type of
sodium loading for performance or
anything like that
now
another question here last one i'm going
to do
can athletes also from adam by the way
can athletes get around the negative
effects of high sugar consumption
because they are more active
uh
the short answer is yes
so
a lot of the med like cardio metabolic
concerns about sugar
are
largely related to very high intakes of
fructose aside from just being in very
positive energy balance uh but fructose
does get a little bit more consideration
a little bit more attention
because fructose is metabolized
differently than other monosaccharides
so fructose
is mostly metabolized in the liver which
can definitely cause some issues
and one of the issues is there's kind of
just like this bottleneck effect of all
these substrates
going to the liver um you know just this
overload of you know carbohydrate and de
novo lipogenesis occurring there and
being in an energy surplus with a
tremendous amount of fructose that's all
kind of going to the liver and not
causing uh great things when it comes to
cardio metabolic health
now
the reason i bring that up is because if
you are physically active and exercising
uh you know when we look at sedentary
folks that are on a
a very high fructose diet we will see
hepatic
de novo lipogenesis so de novo
lipogenesis in the liver we'll see
increases in
uh fat storage within the liver uh we'll
see increases in blood triglyc
triglyceride concentrations uh and uh
also an impairment of insulin
sensitivity so those are the types of
cardio metabolic issues that we're
looking at
that's in sedentary folks who are in
positive energy balance with a
pretty notable influx of
really deliberately high fructose
if you are
active exercising that is clearing a lot
of those substrates out of your liver
there's a lot of energy flux going on
substrates are coming in they're being
utilized that's a good thing substrates
come in substrates go out can't explain
that you can't uh and and i won't
but
there there is a study um that kind of
looked at this exact question um
and if anything this study undersells
uh
the safety mechanisms for the typical
healthy active person but the study was
by smajas and colleagues in 2020 titled
metabolic effects of a prolonged very
high dose dietary fructose challenge and
healthy subjects and that's when you
know that it's a pretty serious
intervention when they're not even
calling it a high fructose diet it's a
high fructose challenge that means the
fructose is pretty high so in this
particular study they were looking at
150 grams of fructose daily which would
be like 300 grams of table sugar on a
daily basis
the fructose equivalent
i
looked at ten healthy subjects um after
eight weeks of adhering to this that
that's a pretty substantial amount of
time that's a lot to have that much
fructose and these are are healthy folks
but they're not like you know
running 15 miles a week or anything like
that just healthy folks who are not
deliberately eating in a you know a
caloric surplus
and
basically body weight decreased slightly
during the study
none of the outcomes they looked at
related to uh the liver or metabolic
health were significantly impacted in a
negative way so if you have um you know
if your body composition is within a
healthy range for you
and you're
quite active and you're not in a large
energy surplus
you know
dealing with sugar even if it's pure
fructose in this example doesn't seem to
be uh
much of a challenge at all it doesn't
seem to be much of a problem so
uh esp for someone who's relatively lean
and exercising regularly uh it is really
not something that is worth
being too concerned about as long as
sugar's not displacing other important
stuff from your diet but you know the
the anecdotal evidence for this is quite
abundant as well um
i don't know many people who have more
sugar than the typical endurance athlete
who's putting in pretty high mileage um
you know we're not seeing a lot of
endurance athletes coming in with you
know non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
or you know metabolic syndrome or things
like that so absolutely
if you're active and especially if you
maintain relatively lean body
composition and you're not in a huge
caloric surplus
you can certainly get around some of
those negative effects of high sugar
consumption
makes sense yeah you uh you said you
were going to knock out those q and a's
pretty quickly and you uh
weren't completely honest about that but
i will try to succeed where you failed
uh i also have several questions to
address
and i'll try to be snappy
so uh this first one i'm not going to
say who posted it because i'm going to
be somewhat critical of the question
itself
and so i don't want to put this person
on blast
but the question was um
i'm a fitness instructor i have a client
um i put them in a calorie deficit but
they're not losing weight is this
because they're lying to me
um
and so first off uh
shout out to uh stronger by science
facebook community member matt cottrell
uh who already
uh did i i think a pretty good job in
the group of answering this person's
question
and pointing out why
uh assuming that they're lying isn't the
most uh useful or productive framework
um
but yeah so uh
to to address this question
first off i uh i disagree with the
premise uh if they're not losing weight
assuming that there's not some sort of
um
some sort of disease state going on
where maybe they're
experiencing massive fluid retention
independent of
energy balance related weight regulation
so for for the vast majority of people
the vast majority of the time
if they're not losing weight they
probably are not in fact in an energy
deficit um
so the the question was uh you know are
they lying about what they're eating um
and
i think most of the time they're they're
probably not uh and that there are
several um
that there are several potential
explanations for why this person isn't
losing weight beyond uh assuming
dishonesty so the first is you know this
individual could just have a lower
energy expenditure than would be
predicted um you know if you
put their
sex height weight activity level in a
formula and it says like ah their
maintenance is probably about 2500
calories and you say like okay
let's let's have a nice modest deficit
let's go 2 200 calories and they're not
losing weight it very well could just be
that their energy expenditure is 2200
calories and not 2500 so you know
when you're dealing with a modest
intended deficit there is a chance that
they're actually eating exactly what you
ask them to um but they're not actually
in a deficit because their energy
expenditure is a little is a little bit
lower than you would predict
um
another
pretty common possibility
and i think this is probably the most
i think this is probably the issue that
a lot of personal trainers or nutrition
coaches run into especially
if they're working with gen pop clients
is that uh they think that they're
eating what you've asked them to but
they're just not doing a great job of
tracking things so
maybe they're eyeballing their
measurements um maybe that maybe there
are things that they're just simply not
tracking so
you know for example uh if you make some
eggs and you throw a little bit of oil
in the pan like yeah you track the eggs
wasn't much oil i don't need to track
that put a little bit of cream in your
coffee like yeah it was just a splash
like it's fine i don't i don't want to
measure that small amount of cream i'm
sure it's okay throw a little bit of
dressing on your salad especially if
it's a light dressing like yeah do i
really need to worry about tracking it
uh so just little inaccuracies and
things that aren't tracked throughout
the day can add up to several hundred
calories so again
if someone
was intended to be in a relatively
modest deficit it could just be that
that they think they're being completely
honest with you and and accounting for
all of the major things they need to
account for but they're just having
issues with tracking and uh
you know you can address that with them
just via some education like ask like
hey
are you tracking the dressing you put on
your salad or you know whatever else um
that's a common thing in research by the
way is um you know
they'll they'll get the food diary from
the individual and then do kind of a
guided interview and they'll say oh i
noticed you had cereal for breakfast
this day
no milk and they're like oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah they will go through and be
like a plain hot dog no no condiments on
that you know so they'll go through it
much like you just described yeah yeah
um so yeah
i think
in excess of 80 of the time if
someone swears up and down that they're
eating what you ask them to
um and you know they should be losing
weight but they're not it's all it often
just comes down to inaccurate tracking
which you know you don't have to assume
that someone is being dishonest if
they're tracking inaccurately because
without a bit of education i think just
naturally most people don't do a great
job of tracking um and that's you know
that's the standard state of things and
it's a-okay and it's it's on you as
a trainer to to teach them those skills
um
another pretty common thing that could
be happening is
uh if someone doesn't have a habit of
tracking nutrition they could just be
eating things not thinking about it and
not tracking it and again that doesn't
imply dishonesty i i think it's a
relatively common
a relatively common habit uh when you
first start tracking to
associate pulling out your phone or
pulling out the paper you're
writing your food diary on
when you're about to sit down to a meal
and you kind of associate those two
things
but you know if you just like pop into a
bodega on on the way home and just like
grab grab a little snack
it may just not occur to you
that you ate something you know it could
just be such a part or like if someone
brings donuts into the office like if
you're not already kind of in the mode
of like oh if i
consume something i'm going to track it
it could just be a matter of people
eating without thinking about it and not
logging it if this is a relatively new
habit to them um
and then another very common thing is uh
people
going off script on their diet i don't
want to say that uh they're having a
cheat meal because i think the word
cheat uh has some moral implication that
uh it might be undeserved but you know
they go off script and they think like
ah i only went a little bit off script
but they actually went quite a bit
further off script than they realized uh
and again that's that's not dishonesty
that's uh just simply not doing a great
job of accounting for how off script you
went uh and in my in my experience the
biggest culprit there is drinks like if
you go out you get some drinks at the
bar
um
man you can put down a thousand calories
of alcohol pretty quickly and uh since
it goes down smooth you're like ah maybe
400 calories but i mean that 600 calorie
gap is is a pretty big gap uh so yeah
there are a lot of possibilities where
um this individual thinks that they're
uh eating about what they were assigned
to eat and they are being honest when
they say they think they're sticking to
the plan pretty well um but but they're
just not for those reasons um so yeah i
i think that those are
things that you should explore with with
this client um
and don't necessarily assume they're
being dishonest
i mean if you've coached enough people
you will
you will get some uh just very dishonest
clients from time to time uh
and i mean you'll just deal with
dishonest people in life from time to
time but in in my experience that shit's
pretty rare like most people especially
if they're paying you for a service
they're not just gonna like purposefully
straight up lie to your face uh because
doing so is wasting their money
like going into the doctor for a problem
and they're like do you have any
symptoms no yeah not at all it's like
well if you don't tell me like i can't
help you know yeah like no one's gonna
do that intentionally like most people
are fundamentally pretty honest and
they can relay inaccurate information
without lying you know like and and so
this brings me to a meadow point kind of
underpinning this question
i think that there's a general tendency
to think um
if i said or if i did
what this other person is saying or
doing
i would be dishonest if i did that um
but a an assumption there is like you're
maybe being
empathetic in a negative way you're
putting yourself in someone's shoes
assuming that they know what you know um
which sometimes isn't a good assumption
to make uh so to to move past the
coaching point i i see this
a lot of times when when folks are
discussing say content they come across
on the internet or on social media and
it's like oh like so-and-so's just lying
to their audience for the cloud or to
make profit or whatever and like i don't
know
there's plenty of that i'm sure that i'm
sure that it occurs but
i think a lot of i think a lot of that
comes down to the thought process of
if i was saying what this other person
was saying
i would know that i was making incorrect
statements and therefore i would be
lying and therefore this other person is
lying
when i think more often than not it's
just people who are either uninformed or
misinformed
who are spreading misinformation but
they they think they're being honest
about it um like they they don't realize
that they're
uh
relaying false information to people uh
and so i think that that's
just something to keep in mind
and
and when someone does or says something
that would imply that you personally
would be acting in bad faith if you said
or did the same thing that doesn't
necessarily imply that the other person
is acting in bad faith because they may
just not know what you know
one thing to add yeah my the classic
thing that gets overlooked so like you
know
condiments dressings oh yeah those are
classics
if your client has children
extra bites of food that the kids didn't
eat oh yeah that is a classic that a lot
of people forget when they're going
through with a client if your client has
kids that should be item number one
very common here's another one uh i
don't know how common this is outside of
the south
but um
in talking about nutrition with
southern individuals who are say
yeah 55 60 plus
and to be clear i'm not talking [ __ ]
about the south i was born and raised in
the south uh love it dearly but
uh
man a lot of older southern people and
i'm not saying this applies to everyone
but a lot of older southern people
simply don't realize that beverages have
calories like
you would be shocked at the number of
you know
southern women southern gentlemen in
their 60s or 70s who
subsist
solely on a
like all of the liquid they consume is
soft drinks or coffee with a bunch of
cream and sugar in it
and it just doesn't occur to them that
those calories really matter
like if if you're not chewing it
it doesn't really have calories does it
uh and that's i mean that's
again i don't know the degree to which
that generalizes but uh in at least a
particular region of the united states
that that might be something to bring up
with people and i can tell you now i'm a
southern gentleman i've been here for
long enough to call myself that but when
i first moved to the region and i i
first watched someone make
sweet tea oh hell yeah
sweet tea in the southern region of the
united states is the only place you can
get sweet tea the real sweet tea well
it's like a modern marvel it's an
innovation there is no way to get more
sugar
suspended into a liquid solution i've
never seen anything like it yeah if
someone said they made sweet tea but
they didn't add the sugar when the water
was still boiling they did not make
sweet tea because without the water
currently being boiling
it cannot accept
enough sugar to qualify a sweet tea yeah
um
anyway so yeah uh you know if someone
says something that you that would be a
lie if you said it don't necessarily
assume that it's a lie because they said
it because
uh they may not know what you know all
right moving on uh
speaking of which i've already lied uh i
said i was going to be quick that wasn't
that quick uh okay dominic canizaro asks
a simple question recognizing needs will
vary by person how critical is adequate
sleep to gains to body comp and are
negative effects more acute or chronic
there's no shortage of fear-mongering
and quote-unquote common wisdom out
there but a lot of quote-unquote general
sleep data
has had doubt cast upon it uh he's
referencing matthew walker's book why we
sleep in particular there um
we we've discussed that book on the
podcast before and how
uh it's it's a little bit sketchy uh
i don't remember what episode check it
out in the archives um someone published
uh a very very very thorough critique of
it just the first chapter just the first
chapter saying there's like a 12 000
word article that was just like let's go
through these claims one by one and just
i think he planned on fact checking the
entire book and he just found so much
[ __ ] in just the first chapter it
was basically just like i think i've
made my point yeah yeah
um okay uh
so yeah uh how how much does sleep
matter for um
gains and body comp
and uh to what degree are the effects
acute versus chronic
so the thing about sleep research is
where
if you're attempting to draw inferences
you're generally attempting to draw
inferences based on two types of data
either um
either just like correlational data
where on the population level do we
consistently see differences between
people who sleep more sleep less uh or
um like longitudinal cohort studies
where you look to see over time do we
see
uh dif different changes in various
regards for the people who sleep more or
sleep less within the cohort um
which you know that's obviously not
tremendously high quality evidence
because there could be plenty of
confounders which maybe you tried to
control for statistically that's not
quite as good as running an rct or you
know maybe they're just confounders that
you either don't think about or just are
unable to attempt to control force
statistically so
you know that's not uh
a lack of evidence but that is uh
relatively low quality evidence on kind
of the the hierarchy of evidence or the
other type of research you'll see uh rct
or crossover studies that are very
short-term so you know maybe a sleep
deprivation study or a sleep restriction
study that runs for like two weeks or
you just look uh to see the acute
effects of one night of sleep
restriction or full sleep deprivation um
which you know that allows you to draw
causal inferences but then there's a
question of generalizability um
do changes that occur after
one night of poor sleep does that
generalize to
you know six months of somewhat iffy but
not super poor quality sleep you know um
so yeah any uh when you're talking about
body comp or especially like strength
and hypertrophy any inferences you draw
have to be very tentative because
long-term high-quality rcts simply don't
exist for the reason that it would be
impossible to recruit for a study like
that uh if if someone put out a flyer
and they said like hey we're doing a
study to see how sleep affects gains and
i saw that flyer and said ah interesting
i would like to contribute to the
scientific process i will volunteer for
this study i volunteer for the study
show up to the lab and they say we've
randomized you into the sleep
restriction group you're going to be
sleeping six hours a night
every night for the next four months i'd
say ah well i appreciate you no naps
yeah yeah no sleep in it on the weekends
i'd say i appreciate you getting back
with me uh but i'm going to have to
politely decline your offer to
participate in this study um
and i think virtually everyone would
approach it the same way
uh so yeah i don't think we're ever
gonna see high-quality rcts so uh what i
can say
is uh we've talked about this on the
podcast before
um sleep extension studies have pretty
promising results so there have been a
few studies uh sherry ma
dr sherry ma uh is the the main
researcher in this area even though i
don't think i've seen a new paper on
this subject from her um
in the last like three or four years
but uh there have been a handful of
studies where they take relatively high
level collegiate athletes and they have
uh
and they basically say like yeah you
sleep seven ish hours per night what if
you just slept nine or ten for a few
weeks and then you observe the changes
and they they do tend to find
uh pretty striking improvements in a
pretty wide array of measures
pretty quickly so everything from
hand-eye coordination which you might
expect just because people might be a
little bit less sleepy so you know they
looked at tennis serve accuracy free
throw accuracy in basketball those types
of things improve
um but then just like
anaerobic performance tends to improve
as well so there was a study looking at
like swimming sprint speed uh the
basketball study included some some
sprint type outcomes and you see some
pretty striking improvements and stuff
like that in pretty high level athletes
pretty quickly um
but again we're not talking about
tremendously long interventions there
and they don't also include like a
long-term sleep restriction group for
comparison uh but that stuff's pretty
promising on the body comp uh side of
things probably the best study we have
which i know i've written about for
stronger by science like back in 2014 or
so
and i think we've mentioned it on the
podcast before there's a paper called
insufficient sleep undermines dietary
efforts to reduce adiposity
this was a very well controlled but very
short-term study
where
subjects were in a calorie deficit and
sleeping either eight and a half hours
per night or five and a half hours per
night for 14 days straight
they found that sleep restriction didn't
impact the total amount of weight that
was lost but the proportion of weight
that was lost that came from lean mass
rather than fat mass
was quite a bit greater when when people
were sleeping five and a half hours per
night
i mean two weeks two weeks isn't great
but i think that's about the longest
sleep restriction type study we're gonna
see so i do think um
you know i do think
we could maybe conclude that if you're
or we could draw a weak inference that
if you're trying to maintain as much
muscle as possible when dieting
trying to sleep enough is probably
pretty important and then as far as as
muscle related stuff goes
really all we have to go on is is
mechanisms uh insufficient sleep can
reduce sex hormone production
um in since uh
your your biggest
growth hormone pulses and therefore
subsequent igf-1 pulses uh largely come
at night subsequent to pulsed melatonin
releases
uh
you know your kind of 24-hour area under
the curve for several major anabolic
hormones might be reduced if you're not
sleeping enough maybe that's going to
have negative impacts on muscle if
you're
already generally healthy though it's
it's hard to say that for sure
another thing we know is that not
sleeping enough generally tends to mess
with hunger and satiety cues so
um even independent of maybe
uh direct effects on body composition it
might make it a little bit harder to
stick to a
reduced calorie diet um
you know just because you might be a
little bit hungrier and
also may just have uh bigger issues with
impulse control like that's something
that comes with uh with sleep
restriction as well
um
one thing i'll note though as well on
the exercise side of things and i
uh did not grab studies to put in the
outline just take my word on it i think
we've talked about some of these on the
podcast before
um exercise tends to
so one acute sleep restriction tends to
have less of an effect on strength and
anaerobic performance
than you'd probably expect
so
even one night of complete sleep
deprivation
um
your performance will probably be
hindered if you're trying to do a really
high volume resistance training session
but just like the ability to kind of get
up and go and perform pretty well for a
low to moderate amount of volume
is generally preserved pretty well
acutely after just one or two nights of
pretty poor sleep um and then on kind of
the muscle side of things there have
been some studies that have looked at uh
like baseline muscle protein synthesis
in a well-rested versus sleep-deprived
state finding that
mps is reduced to some degree but then
you put a resistance training stimulus
into the mix and the post exercise
muscle protein synthesis rates seem to
be pretty similar uh regardless of the
preceding night of sleep
um
so yeah like short term you seem to be
able to perform pretty well and you
still get a pretty decent muscle protein
synthetic response who knows what those
effects would look like
extrapolated you know beyond a single
day to multiple weeks i do kind of think
that it's it's probably going to have a
negative impact on your gains to some
degree uh but
um
you know at this point we're
we're teetering along the line of
uh drawing weak inferences from data and
just pure speculation
so
i would say overall sleep is a good
thing
uh i i personally think that sleeping
enough is probably gonna have
i feel quite confident saying it's gonna
have beneficial effects on body comp
and i'm reasonably confident assuming
that it's going to have beneficial
effects
on your ability to get stronger and
build muscle
but what i would also say is that anyone
who's trying to put
strict precise numbers on the magnitude
of that impact is uh
they're just making [ __ ] up
uh the the evidence simply doesn't exist
to kind of give
granular expectations for what to expect
with
sufficient versus insufficient sleep
all right uh this will be a quick one
philip
gramatif
god this guy comments on our stuff all
the time i should know how to pronounce
his name it's so many syllables
gramatikovsky i think that's
correct gramatikovsky yeah all right uh
so phillip asks much of sports science
studies are conducted on young males are
there any studies uh or areas in
particular that we would have reason to
think female physiology would give
different results
um
you know that's a good question um
and i'm not totally
in terms of in terms of the physiology
thing i mean i think the the biggest
thing to consider
um
is that
uh
certain
certain supplements in just certain
chemical compounds
uh
uh sex hormones and in particular
estrogen can affect
how they're metabolized and the rate at
which they're metabolized and i know
we've talked about this on the podcast
before
but but kind of the poster child for
that is uh caffeine so
the rate at which
women metabolize caffeine
uh varies based on where they're at in
their menstrual cycle and might vary
between uh women using versus not using
hormonal contraception so
um
on a physiological level i mean anything
that might be interacting with sex
hormones or where sex hormones might
interact with the rate at which certain
compounds are metabolized uh
i think those would be the the places to
look if you're asking about this purely
from a phys
physiology
basis
personally though uh i'm going to answer
this question just you know what what
areas are there
quite is there quite a bit of research
on males where i'd like to see more
research on females
um
and the first thing that comes to mind
which
uh generally wouldn't be the first thing
that would come to mind for me uh
because i generally don't care about
them
is uh supplements a lot of supplement
research uh there's a lot of studies on
males not that many on females uh
caffeine used to be one actually where
uh like 98 of the research was was on
male subjects uh and i think we talked
about this maybe two episodes ago but
within the last two years there's
there's been a uh
a renaissance
can't call it a renaissance that's a
rebirth there's been an initial sons
of uh
exercise caffeine research in women so
that that's good to see but yeah a lot
of supplements uh bodies of research
lean very heavily towards male subjects
so i'd like to see
more female supplement studies
um one area where i'm particularly
interested uh in like
muscle type outcomes in women
is blood flow restriction research a lot
of that stuff leans pretty heavily uh
towards the male side of things and
there have been some initial studies
suggesting that maybe blood flow
restriction is uh
it has a it might have a slightly
smaller anabolic effect in uh females
muscles than males muscles um
but again we we need to see some more
research before i could say that uh
pretty confidently but that's that's an
area where i'd like to see more research
on women um
and i think the last one is i'd like to
see more
uh more studies comparing high load and
low load training in uh in women
uh for a long time there there were
a dozen studies in men and there was a
2012 paper by schwinke uh
that was the only high load low load
study in women
since then i think there have been
either two or three more studies um
that that have
found results that are similar to the
research on men
in that high load and low load training
seem to have uh fairly similar effects
on hypertrophy uh the schwenke study
though did find that high load training
was way way more effective than low load
training for hypertrophy in women uh and
there there hasn't been like a major
result like that on the male side of
things
uh so
i i would want to see
i think another probably two or three
high load low load uh hypertrophy
studies
in women
and actually there's one more i'd like
to see uh
more volume studies in women as well
like the impact of training volume on
hypertrophy and strength gains
most of most of that research
uses male subjects or predominantly male
subjects
and there's some reason to believe that
women
both maybe can tolerate higher levels of
training volume within a single session
like recovering better set to set
maybe recovering a little bit better
between resistance training sessions
than males do
so there's some reason to believe that
the optimal training volume for women
might be a little bit higher than the
optimal training volume for men
so i'd like to see uh more volume
studies on women
individually but then also
comparing the effects of various levels
of training volume uh in both males and
females within this within the context
of the same study to see if
kind of that optimal level of volume um
seems to on average differ between sexes
i i suspect it does but there's there's
not enough research
currently to say for sure
good stuff
do you have any that you'd like to see
um
[Music]
nothing that really comes to mind like
i feel like
you already mentioned it but with the
supplement research there's just so much
that is
male heavy yeah um
and it has
it's changing you know um
there are a lot of studies coming out
that um
you know
pretty explicitly are just like yeah
we're testing this in in female
participants because we think we know
about this supplement and we've never
tried yeah um yeah we think we know the
effects of this supplement but
when we look at the extant literature we
realize we only know the effects of this
supplement in about 49 of the population
yeah um
you know i i would be
just like an interesting aspect of
physiology i think is metabolic
flexibility
and given
differences in substrate utilization i
think it might be interesting to look at
uh how different nutritional patterns
could potentially influence uh metabolic
flexibility in males versus females
i'm not sure it would be particularly
uh you know actionable you know i don't
think i don't i'm not certain that there
would be a high degree of practical
application uh but i just think it's a
fascinating concept yeah um
diverge yeah i i think it'd be
interesting to look at um you know
more research on sex differences uh
in terms of different weight loss
strategies um different dietary
combinations and
um you know much like people have kind
of speculated that you know individuals
who are more insulin resistant might do
better on this diet versus that diet i
think
the more that we continue to explore
these kind of open research questions
the better but there's there's not like
one
um
one particular topic where i'm like
that's that's what i'd like to see i
gotcha oh uh this this wouldn't
necessarily be a males versus females
thing uh but one one other area where
i'd like to see more research in in
women in particular uh is looking at the
effects of uh menstrual cycle phase on
recovery from resistance training there
was a really cool paper by markowski in
2014 that looked at this uh finding that
recovery from
like a pretty brutal eccentric exercise
session uh was was considerably quicker
during the follicular phase of the cycle
versus the ludial phase
and i think that there's been maybe one
maybe two other papers since then that
have that have waded into those waters
but uh
man there's been a lot of there's been a
lot of research on uh the impact of the
menstrual cycle on
acute exercise performance across
basically every conceivable domain of
performance
you know aerobic capacity
repeated sprint performance maximum
dynamic strength maximum isometric
strength all types of stuff looking at
uh how different menstrual cycle phases
affect various things turns out not all
that much uh really but
there hasn't been that much
looking at the effects of menstrual
cycle phases on recovery which
theoretically could have a notable
impact
because
sex hormones seem to influence recovery
from
muscle damage in in women quite a bit um
so estrogen tends to promote uh like
muscular healing and recovery uh post
training um you you can see that
in women with different estrogen levels
you can see that when women go on
hormone replacement therapy um like if
they're post-menopausal um
and i mean just like kind of mechanistic
cell culture research shows that as well
there was a good a good review paper on
that i think from 2010 by ends and
colleagues en and s
um
but yeah so
theoretically with with fluctuating
estrogen levels uh throughout the
menstrual cycle
you could conceivably predict uh
different rates of of recovery from
resistance training and like i said that
markovsky study
suggests that it might have a have a
relatively large impact um
but yeah i want to see more follow-up
work in that area
before stating that with with a super
high degree of confidence so that's
that's another area where where i
definitely like to see more research
let's uh let's move on i've got two more
i think they should be pretty quick as
well yeah we're about two and a half
hours into the episode by the way hell
yeah okay so this next one we already
have the answer lightning bolt 66 from
reddit asks is there anything within the
industry that you and eric fundamentally
disagree on
and uh
i'm going to say no because i don't want
to get kicked off the podcast and that's
uh
yeah i think we can leave it at that
all right and finally also from reddit
gravity fighter asks the big
breakthrough in the supplement world was
creatine and everyone's always looking
for the next creatine one of the major
breakthroughs in powerlifting training
in the in the powerlifting training
world was through mike t's rts uh if
there is to be another major
breakthrough in powerlifting training
which area of training do you see it
being in
um
and i i think uh
i think if we could develop better
screening tools to
more efficiently uh personalize and
individualize training i think that that
would be
kind of the the next big step forward um
because i mean ultimately that's what it
comes down to that's that's what good
coaches do they motivate people to work
hard and they figure out what works well
on a individual athlete by athlete basis
like those are those are the two
kind of most important skills for
coaches i think um
but ultimately when you're trying to
individualize training
especially if you're dealing with people
who are relatively well trained already
is you're trying to make fairly precise
inferences from pretty noisy data so if
you're dealing with someone who like
an excellent training cycle they might
put
10 15 pounds on their squat
but also you know just day-to-day
performance fluctuates so
you know their one rep max squat might
vary by 15 pounds day to day the
difference between a good training like
a great training cycle and not a great
training cycle where they don't actually
get any stronger
you might not even be able to tell that
over the course of a single training
cycle because you know bad training
cycle but just a good testing day at the
end cool looks like you put 15 pounds on
your squat uh excellent training cycle
where you have an average testing day
you put 15 pounds on your squat you know
ultimately you're you're looking
you're dealing with somewhat noisy
measurements looking for relatively
small changes
and uh generally looking for for pretty
um
pretty specialized training
interventions like
you know if if you're dealing if you're
trying to figure out like the optimal
level of training volume for someone or
like if a particular accessory lift is
working well for them like those are
those are relatively uh
those are questions that lend themselves
to relatively precise answers and
it can be hard to find the signal in the
noise um
and ultimately the total pool of
questions you could ask in total
training interventions you could try on
an individual
is virtually infinite
so i think if there are if we had better
screening tools and you know maybe it's
it's uh based on like genetics once
genetic screening becomes better maybe
it's based on like
i don't know whatever else who the [ __ ]
knows uh but i i think if we had tools
where like at baseline before going
through a multi-month or multi-year
process of trying to figure out the
optimal approach to training for an
individual
if you could just do some basic
screening and get them
pretty close pretty quickly um
i think one more people would be exposed
to training that is more appropriate for
them in their unique physiology which
would be great
and also
functionally it would allow people to
reach a higher training age sooner like
i think a lot of people have the
experience of
training for a while kind of getting
decent results and then finally hitting
on a style of training that works really
well for them and that's kind of what
allows them to take take a step to the
next level of kind of whatever they're
training for but if you could just start
there at whatever style of training lets
you get to that next level
you know functionally you could uh
be training for a year but be in the
same general place that you may have
taken five years to get to otherwise so
you know when when you're dealing with
powerlifting you want people to get
pretty [ __ ] strong pretty young so
that they have time to to build and
mature um
and so yeah if you could
basically skip that period that a lot of
people experience where their training
time isn't wasted but it's not used
super productively um i think that that
would be really valuable so yeah the
better better tools to
uh screen and individualize training
better for individuals from the jump um
again i'm not totally sure what that
would look like but i i think if
something like that were to present
itself that that would be a pretty big
step forward
yeah it would be cool if if we could get
some like
really large powerlifting
programs
uh
to kind of get on board with some
meticulous record keeping
to just start developing like an
enormous database of
some key characteristics
general trajectories in terms of uh
progression for the lifter i mean to get
to some of these individualized uh
nuances
the need for
for data is pretty overwhelming i mean
just the the sheer volume of data that
would be needed to support any kind of
thorough statistical analysis is
it would take quite a feat quite an
effort to make that to make that viable
it would be doable but logistically it
would take some serious buy-in yeah but
it'd be very very cool if someone were
to organize something that
sounds anything like that that'd be cool
absolutely
all right uh to play us out um
bear week is over and bear week is also
canceled um i have canceled it we have
cancelled it um
so
i put my money i put a lot of money on
chunk to win it all and i know that you
were pulling for grazer
and the
winner
as they're calling it was 480 otis
many people are calling him sleepy otis
yeah
so this is
the fourth title for 480 otis uh 2014
2016
2017
and 2021
i mean this is like an alabama type run
that otis is on
um
a lot of
i guess i would say irregularities in
terms of the composition of the bracket
yeah i i would say so um
i you have nothing to complain about
chunk got a first-round buy which uh
many people are saying was very
undeserved
uh
i think i think uh as as a grazer fan
i'm very upset with uh the bracket they
gave her first they made her compete
against 435 holly in the first round uh
you know
forcing
strong women to fight with each other uh
over scraps that that's that's
functionally a glassy because only one
can can go onto the elite eight exactly
they're saying like look we can have a
female bear in the elite eight but we
can't have two uh i think i think the
implication with the seeding was obvious
and you can do without what you will
because they were the only two females
right i don't know if that's the case
that's what you told me when you were
upset about this priest
those are the those are the only two
female names on the other side of the
bracket there are some bears that only
have numbers attached to them and uh
well though
they could have potentially done more
research that makes it worse to me
because the other side of the bracket
480 otis is the only bear with a name
every other bear only has a three-digit
number yeah that that is true they they
gave him a [ __ ] cake walk yeah humans
are voting on this and who are you going
to vote for a fat bear named otis or 8
12. yeah so come on you're going to vote
for otis for for people following him
sleepwalk to the championship round
literally every bear on the left side of
the bracket has a cute name
and otis was the only bear with a name
on the right side of the bracket so on
the left side you're like oh look at
little chunk and look at the little baby
cub who should have won by a landslide
yeah i didn't even notice that that's
yeah that's [ __ ] yeah so my god
needless to say we're upset the fix was
in yeah but yeah so they they made holly
and grazer fight uh it can only have one
female in the elite eight and then what
what do they do in the next round of
course holly steam or of course grazer
steamrolled in the first round because
she was always going to she's a star but
yeah then uh they gave 132 cub very cute
you should look up pictures they gave
the cub a first round bye
and
put the cub on the same side of the
bracket as holly and grazer so the
winner of that round was gonna have to
go up against a cub next which yeah i
shouldn't have to uh
i shouldn't have to spell out how
patently unfair that is you know like
if if they thought uh you know otis
multi-time returning champion if they
thought he that otis had the juice they
should have put otis up against the cub
that's all i'm saying so anyway uh 132
cub did take down grazer i can't be that
upset about it that cub's so cute yeah
um
anyway you know
yeah this
this fat bear week
has left a very
a very sour taste in my mouth and i
don't know that i can ever trust
democracy again but it's just like any
other sport when your team loses in the
playoffs and you're like you know what i
invested so much in this season and i'm
so upset and angry and disappointed i'm
not doing this again i'm out like this
sport is dead to me but where are we
going to be next october filling out our
brackets that's true we simply can't
stay away from fat bear week katmai
national park and preserve simply cannot
keep us away no
uh but anyway it seems like it's the
same uh same general group of characters
every year so i mean you can really
start to
develop some serious attachment to the
bear of your choice so chunk will be
back and we'll do our best in 2022.
uh all right that does it for this
episode as always thanks for joining us
and we will be back soon